let's let's jump to this next story
this is uh
this is fun cnn's new ceo plans to prune
partisan personalities and programming i
hope they fire brian celtic poor brian
upon taking over from for jeff zucker
chris licht has vowed to make changes
among them as a reduction of partisan
programming and on-air personalities
if he gets his way
on-air talent could be ousted if they
can't adjust to a less partisan tone and
strategy so here's here's going to
happen brian stalter is going to do a
segment where he goes this is exactly
right we shouldn't be partisan it's
funny how whatever you do his voice very
well what whatever whatever the company
wants to do he's just like of course
that's the right answer but here's the
problem for brian
one day i don't know when it will be but
one day they will actually make hiring
and firing decisions based on ratings
that is the day that brian sees
the end of the road so i mean obviously
i support this i think this is great but
let's just make it a meritocracy
and but if they did that then tucker
would be on cnn yeah
yep i mean it's crazy how the cable
cable news used to be tucker was on
msnbc
really when he used to have he
nbc used to be kind of like corporate
right or like you know it was like a
crossfire thing right no no i think i
think msnbc was considered to be like
center right or something oh wow yeah
it's only it's only recently that msnbc
turned into a far hard left weird
liberal democrat thing i think that's a
lie really no yeah yeah yeah sounds like
fake news to me they got bought by
comcast at some point um interesting
didn't they have jesse ventura on and
yeah
in 2008 and they cancelled his contract
because he criticized the war when they
told him to stop
um
[Music]
yeah his middle tucker carlson was on
msnbc yeah he's like the situation you
know when comcast
and rachel maddow and jay severin were
featured guests
interesting isn't it crazy how this
stuff used to be yeah now i don't think
tucker carlson
if anything he's become more populist
yes so he used to be very staunch
conservative he was a conservative guy
on crossfire so him being on msnbc msnbc
was not this hard left weirdo thing it
is now
i think
but
it looks like it's been moving less
since 2008 that's when they canceled
tucker
that's just what i'm seeing i did not
know this i don't know that's nbc i had
no idea i've only regretted them as i
thought it wasn't only me yeah no i i
followed the news closely and i was like
so that's 2009 is when comcast
uh well actually they announced that
they were buying nbc universal and then
it was 2013 when they actually bought
universal now you see blackrock state
street and vanguard own 20 or whatever
18 of comcast
uh so it's just this media consolidation
see what the banks with wells fargo now
owns whatever else other banks and
comcast
is just dictating the narrative yeah the
more you consolidate anything like that
i think the worse it's going to be i
think we are seeing all this
corporatization because at the end of
the day like three companies own
everything bet you that more people
watch
your
show
more people listen to it that's for sure
and i'm not talking about words they're
hearing i'm not saying they're hearing
more people hearing i'm saying they're
actually listening yeah no i mean i this
i mean this is the brian stelter thing
you can respond to this show it's a
completely different ballgame but this i
mean
it's
that's why it's popular though because
people feel like
there is they're invested in it and they
are part of this yeah whereas brian
stelter when you watch it you just feel
like you're
you're on the receiving end of a really
bad lecture who would sign up for that
yeah that media that whole uh that genre
is is gone it doesn't doesn't make sense
i mean some people i guess are used to
it so they're still comfortable with
being talked at but so we i just pulled
up adweek's ratings are up to date but
they don't let you read them unless you
log in and you can't log in because the
system doesn't work for whatever reason
so but i pulled up this is from national
media spots msn so fox news 1.5 million
in uh
what what what is there what is that
number is this prime time
i don't know i think it's i think it's
prime time viewership peak so fox news
gets 1.5 million their average viewer
though is i think what 62 yeah yeah okay
they do get a lot on the advertisers
because oh my gosh yeah pocket catheters
yeah
but but i think tucker gets around 400
to 500 000 key demo viewers
which is uh basically what we get
it's about the same number but we're not
getting any of the other demographic
right like that we don't get any target
demographics so tucker gets you know
three to five million people watching
his show
ten percent of them are key demo he has
massive influence i wish that you hadn't
said that now i'm just gonna sit here
terrified the rest of the show i
intentionally shield myself from this
kind of information what like how big
the show yeah i just i like to think of
just to sit next to us
but it's but it's also different too
because we get that
over
the life of the sh so like
i think
off-season politics we're getting like
350 to 450 uh on youtube and then we get
like 100 on the podcast
then we do the clips which get another
six or seven hundred right right so
it's different from how cable tv works
yeah yeah but it's it's definitely
changing and changing for the better so
i'm what i'm wondering is
i'm wondering you know from an internal
business perspective and from a cultural
perspective what's the upward limit of a
show like this can we ever be as big as
sucker crosstalk it can be infinite i
don't think so neural net it can be
infinite everyone on earth can know
everyone on earth it can really be like
that well i i don't think i don't think
that's possible right now and there's no
reason to predict in the foreseeable
future that would be the case yeah i
would give it 70 years or something when
people watch cable tv there's like seven
channels they would choose from on cable
news
and that means automated all of the
conservative people are going to watch
tucker when tucker's on when it comes to
the internet you can watch this you can
watch viva you could watch jimmy
watch crowder like it's it's it's made
me realize how small the world really is
when you when you break through you make
a youtube video and then 18 million
people know who you are the next day and
then
with the neural net i mean i don't want
to i don't want to break the
conversation and start talking about
tech that doesn't exist yet but it seems
like we're headed towards an environment
where we're more interoperable as
i think fame is going away and i
predicted this 10 years ago i was at um
what is it called nab in amsterdam
national association of broadcasters and
i was talking to these guys and i said
fame as we know it is going away and
they're like no it isn't that's not true
that'll never happen
and i said
what i explained to them was the
internet is decentralizing how we
consume media
new clicks new groups new subcultures
are emerging and they're exponentially
emerging so where it used to be that
there were ten channels there were three
channels to choose from then there was
five then there was ten
you would have one guy on that nightly
show with you know the with johnny
carson or whatever how many guests would
they have two or three
and so everyone in the country has to
choose between these five channels
so you've got 100 million people
watching tv
20 million watching this one show and
that one guy that's on it is seen by all
of those people i mean this is now it's
it's
there's there's 50 shows to choose from
yeah and i think that this is part of a
larger sort of
our our culture is sort of we're not as
connected anymore because it used to be
that everyone used to watch the same
shows and and you listen to the same
music whatever and now you were talking
about some stranger things before the
show i was like i've never seen that
show and i have no intention and i i can
do that i can operate in a world where
i've never seen that show because how
often does stranger things come up in my
everyday life not that often but if this
were 50 years ago and i hadn't seen
johnny carson last night i can't talk at
the dinner table i have nothing to say
and so i i think that it's really sort
of
not just bifurcated but just like
atomizing all of us into our little
bubbles is it a good thing or is it a
bad thing i think it's a bad thing uh
well it depends because it's also the
decentralization of power and
information
it's a good thing when it's meritocratic
what's happening now is
the establishment and the lefty cults
are manipulating the platforms to prop
up bad ideas when bad ideas are propped
up against metacritic ideas then there's
conflict yeah it's painful i don't know
if you call it good or bad but it's pain
spiritually it's painful to not know
what other people are thinking or caring
about well also powerful people
manipulate the perception with bots and
spam accounts and fake accounts to make
ideas look more popular than they
actually are if they have an agenda in
pushing it and that's why i think the
elon musk spam kind of uh debate is a
lot more important than we even
understand right now but but
another aspect to to kind of look at
here is that you know the corporate
media a lot of their viewership is dying
off
they're they're they're slowly you know
passing away of of old age and and i
think you know tim you make a good
statement i think it's the same kind of
statement that andy warhol made when he
said in the future everyone will be
famous for 15 minutes and i think with
you know the digitalization of
everything i think that's where we're
going i think that's where we're at
almost um
as a certainty in in the near future
yeah i mean you think about sort of
america's sweetheart like jennifer
aniston and sandra bullock and all the
like do we have that today exactly
that's what that's what i'm saying like
does that exist and to me i i'm very
emotionally invested in rachel green aka
jennifer aniston's procreation but now
she's 55 and it's not going to happen
those magazine covers are now over um
and i'm not emotionally invested in
anyone the same way i'm invested in
jennifer garner well i think one thing
that we see
there used to be beloved celebrities
yeah now we have celebrities who are
loved and hated
so well smith yeah well so it's one of
the last ones because back in the day
people were like do we really want to
run
non-stop of the nastiest coverage on
someone that people kind of like a lot
it's risky right if someone is hated and
infamous well then you run the the hits
and the tabloid garbage but if it's a
celebrity you're like people are
interested in celebrity life and
lifestyles of the rich and famous now
though you can hit them both you can
make a magazine called celebrity love
and you can make a magazine called
celebrity gossip where one says will
smith is the best and the other says
will smith is garbage run them both get
both audiences and make money off the
hatred and the positivity yeah meghan
markle is like the the key demo on that
oh
thank you it was so hard to watch fringe
you can she's in a lot by a person what
they think about meghan markle yeah well
why's that she sucks that he's a good
person
this is prince what is it prince harry's
wife yeah i just can't stand the royal
family was that so i disagree with you
on that did you guys see the video of
was that meghan markle talking to the
little kid and the kid was like giving
her the yeah oh that would no that was
prince louis i i'm a royal i'm a really
a royal style tell me about it i'm a
royal fan i've been
imbibing like
you know intravenously all about so you
know a lot about lizards
i got this new ai story general
this is an ai program i i just
subscribed to it's called open ai it's
really amazing you can tell it to do
anything you can say draft me a product
proposal or like give me a catch phrase
and i said tell me a story about donald
trump defeating the lizard people with
his good friend alex jones
and it wrote this really amazing story a
couple of them i i ran where one was
like trump was at a rally when in the
stands he sees a couple lizard people in
masks shouting and he points points him
out and everyone starts booing and then
he goes into the stands with alex jones
like oh he it was it was just an
absolutely ridiculous story one was like
a lizard guy breaks into trump's house
and he throws alex jones's book at him
and hits him in the face knocking him
out making me think of scorpion from
mortal kombat remember that he would
take his mask off and he had like a
lizard mouth we got the masks okay now
what's next that wasn't scorpion
scorpion was a skull okay so we could
hire all of our writers
um you know what i'm thinking luke you
mentioned corporate i you were talking
about the corporations earlier i think
that when a corporation gets big enough
when it becomes a mega corp that it
should no longer be called a corporation
and it should have new laws and rules
about what it can and can't do own land
no you can't own land if you're
uh all sorts of stuff like this like oh
own software private software code no
you can't use that stuff if you're a
mega conglomerate you should be broken
up first of all so we got to figure out
ways to make the system so that it
cannot grow to a place where we're going
to ever have to break it interesting
proposal but a lot of the rules and
regulations made the corporations as
powerful as they are right now because
they made smaller businesses and
competitors at a disadvantage to the
people who are friends with the
politicians so
do you think more rules and laws will
save that that's a question that a lot
of people are asking themselves i'm a
little bit more skeptical of that i'm
very uh libertarian usually for the most
part but there's one thing i think the
government should be focused on is
breaking up monopolies and and making
sure people don't become economical but
they're at the end of the day they're
they're the ones who are going to be
able to get around all the laws like
there's no law that you could write that
would make jeff bezos do anything right
well you can make him free the software
code of his systems you can't make a
copy left i i can't make it but you can
make it illegal not to
i don't agree
they all that happens is it's like
there's 50 million cracks in the surface
and you are plugging one but i can't
give up this is like the founding father
sitting around like there's nothing you
can do to stop king george nothing
i would never not live in that same
thing i mean it's kind of like we're
having that same conversation all over
again with corporations now it's jeff
bezos it's you're inverted it would be
like the king saying there's nothing we
can do to but like if the founding
fathers gave up before they started i
can't give up on this there are
definitely ways we can use law and order
the government would be the crown in
this analogy i think it is no i think
it's bezos i think bezos and the not
jeff particularly jeff but i'm saying
mega corpse are the modern day monarchy
the problem is we're not fighting
fair like at the end of the day we're
all
if we're fighting against jeff bezos
it's in the court of law and
would they have the power in that
circumstance for fighting like
hand-to-hand combat like they they did
in the revolutionary war maybe we have a
chance public opinion is where it's all
at what makes you think that the
government's going to work in the
benefit of the people they never have
there have been studies proving that
it's a scam the special interest the
people with the money essentially call
the shots push the laws they get them
passed because they want them passed
yeah and and they're the ones that are
served here the the super rich we have
socialism for the super rich and
everyone else gets screwed that's
essentially the system that we're living
under right now that was the lesson of
covet amazon made how much money yeah
amazon walmart costco they did a study
and found that public opinion has no
effect on what bills get passed only the
opinion of the top one percent yeah
lobbyists and the people literally when
they would look at they tracked public
sentiment on certain issues and then
bills being passed no correlation right
yeah democracy is a scam the founding
fathers didn't rely on their government
to save them from king george they just
made a new government
i mean so that's basically what has to
happen of course
here we are yeah our revolution starts
here so the the issue is i don't think
it's that hopeless i think
the fact that trump got elected shows
that you can
get somebody in and i think what needs
to happen now is uh robbie starbuck he
won his court battle he's back on the
ballot
we need to go out in the primaries and
vote for
people who actually want to help this
country so here's the problem as someone
who lives somewhere and i tried des you
have to find people willing to do it
and you have to find people willing to
stand up to i i spoke to so many people
i again live in montgomery county
maryland i spoke to so many people who
were incensed by what happened in in
montgomery county they closed the
schools the longest they we were
subjected to all the coveted rules the
longest out of anywhere else in maryland
and people are terrified of standing up
and just saying in and unpop what they
think might be an unpopular thing or
submitting themselves to
the the mob of you know when you run for
office people think that they own your
soul and they try to destroy you i you
have to convince people and so like the
people like robbie starbuck who are
willing to stand up and say i am i'm
ready to fight are so few and far
between because people lack
really really basic courage
yeah i'm thinking about how do you stand
up against a government but the thing is
when i say we need a new government it's
not that we need to trash the u.s
constitution it's great it's the
corporations i'm concerned with and we
can use our government and the structure
of the constitution to defend against
that
the best way to make a government
obsolete is to not need it and not to
depend on it and that's why personal
responsibility is is my choice of a
solution um letting people be healthy
happy healthy and productive and and
just overall living a good life is
something that of course the state does
not want you to have and i think if we
did we wouldn't need a lot of the
government
that we have in our life what do you do
when
the dude who's like two miles upstream
from you and your friend's little
farmhouses starts taking a dump in the
water uh what do you do when monsanto
poises poisons the entire food supply
when they create gmo everywhere what do
you do when they have control of entire
crops that literally spread throughout
the entire world that there's no
stopping right so that's the situation
that we're dealing with but now we have
monsanto protected by the state that's
right bothers me so monsanto is
protected by the state if we didn't have
a state we agree on that when you then
get to the circumstance where
somebody is like upstream from you and
it's a legitimate question i'm not
getting you
how do you like what's the effective way
to respond to someone who's not willing
to cooperate with you and they're like
polluting your water
i know i know the question i know the
big corporations aren't doing it already
like how do we solve this my
counterpoint is yes it's already
happening um we'll deal with that
problem as it comes but that problem is
is less of a problem with that one
individual compared to a multinational
corporation that that literally has a
monopoly and could do whatever they want
and are destroying the soils when we
look at the larger impacts of it is it
an individual stopping this and stopping
this one person okay fine i would argue
that there would be less harm that would
be there would be less pain there would
be less suffering if there was more
decentralization because of
centralization we have monsanto we have
glyphosate we have the rise of horrible
cancers we have the rise of of factory
farming we have the destruction of our
soils that's getting rid of the
nutrients and minerals in there that's
creating very severe health problems for
the rest of the country so i would argue
that with this system we have more pain
and suffering than if we didn't have
this kind of system and if we had more
decentralized what happens when you get
a monopolistic power like monsanto
regardless
people argue from this perspective that
of course the market would respond
people would know that they would be
voting for and supporting something with
their dollar and they wouldn't be doing
so but that that's an argument that's an
argument to be made here
that some people are making the other
perspective of it is of course that
they're so powerful that they can't be
stopped and they'll be willing to do
what they can tell you
in california
you have these small farming communities
with no water because of the drought
yeah and the farmers couldn't get
surface water because it was voted to go
to the cities so they would drill
thousands of feet into the earth for
groundwater
the small farming you know migrant
houses only went down 30 feet for their
well so their wells ran dry very very
quickly this was devastating
and what happens is the people in the
big cities are like
why should i care
to vote in favor of those people right
it doesn't matter if it's your dollar or
your vote your ballot the same thing
would happen that's why i'm like i don't
know what the solution is be it the
state protecting or the private company
just hiring private military to protect
themselves i mean i think a lot of this
sort of goes back to what we were
talking about like the atomization
people just don't care about you know
their fellow man anymore when we have
nothing in common with people and we
don't know who our neighbors are
you don't care about if someone
downstream two houses down you're taking
a dump in their water because you don't
know who they are and you don't care
anything about them this i mean this is
the sort of breakdown of community that
tim carney talks about a lot ben sasse
talks about a lot when we have no
connection to our larger community and
you don't even know i mean do you know
who your neighbor is do you know his
name
i live in an rv i travel
and when i do i do i met an excellent
awesome my last stop was in sarasota as
soon as i pulled into the rv there's a
culture there yeah i had three people
back you know help me get my rv into my
position afterwards two people came to
me and they're like hey look you want to
are you hungry we got food here we're
doing a barbecue there i got two offers
for dinner and i was and and they're
like our you know and you know we talk
about politics and get into different
perspectives
and uh you know people
you know especially in the rv community
are a lot more open and a lot better
than a lot of other people in closed
communities in big cities yeah because
it's very sort of everyone has to help
each other i drive around here people
wave they're super cool people are ready
to communicate it's just a matter of
doing it yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you